really a tragic update to a story we
first shared on monday that little boy
who was rescued from a mobile home fire
has sadly died from his injuries amongst
their grief his family spoke with our
own victoria saha she joins us now to
share what they say happened
ryan three-year-old caiden may chum died
this morning at sunrise hospital family
and fire officials say it was all an
accident
kayden machum is described as a little
boy who loved superheroes he would run
around the house in a cape and wanted to
be the good guy his loss has dug a big
hole in a family that was already
grieving i lost the mother of my child
december 1st on her birthday
couple days later i lose my nephew and i
never would have thought this ever would
have happened ever the family was at a
candlelight vigil sunday night for the
mother of cayden's cousin my daughter
was just so tired trying to she was just
trying to help trying to focus on him
and setting up gofundme for for him
and she was so tired and so anyway when
they got home she
had what whatever she had that she was
lighting candles with at the vigil
it was sitting on her dresser
and he got it while speaking to cayden's
mom off camera she says she woke up
surrounded by flames she rushed out only
to find out caden was still inside when
they found him that he was not breathing
his mom says when she looked back on
surveillance footage kaden was mimicking
what he saw at the candlelight vigil the
night before the grief is
so hard on my daughter right now because
she thinks it's her fault
you know
she's never going to be the same
kaiden's two older sisters were at
school when the fire happened the family
has set up a gofundme that link is up on
our website brian victoria thank you for
that